[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
guys
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
family
dollars
[Music]
[Applause]
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
flashlight
[Music]
[Applause]
s
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not getting soft
foreign
[Music]
let's make this recipe
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm asking
questions
[Music]
test my one test mic one
test mic two
[Music]
test mic three
test my fourth
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to other
people in Hans Kim Give It Up to
yourselves we're coming out here tonight
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Austin Texas who's ready to
date other people
well sign up then there's not enough of
you no just kidding uh we're gonna have
a great time uh my name is Hans Kim I'm
a uh multi multi-dating Champion uh
dated multiple people before
[Music]
um
so yeah I love dating so that's kind of
why I made this show is just to Showcase
my uh skills
um Step number one in dating is uh
always take off the pants before you lay
down just way harder to take them off
after
um yeah tips like that I'll just
sprinkle throughout the show
um it's really not about me though it's
about our guests tonight a real life cow
herder and a man who is good at you know
farming and probably you know it doesn't
like minorities that much uh please go
down for Rich fish burger
thank you
he is hello Ridge Hershberger sure yeah
let's just bring everything anywhere you
want all right it's America after all
yeah you're not used to not being able
to move tables out on the farm
yeah
but you got your notes yeah I have some
questions
[Music]
he's been staring at you people just
writing things down again notepad look
at all these anyways
um you were saying you're a really good
dater yes I have never dated anyone for
more than two weeks
oh is that a grown yeah oh Rich what
happens after two weeks you just you
can't get hard anymore I just
it's not always about that
there's the cows run away after that
they find a bigger dick huh interesting
foreign
now we're all lit up so we can hear why
Ridge is such a loser
two weeks and I'm not interested if I
don't want to marry her I'm like ah you
know I don't know so you put in the
two-week notice right away
I'm gonna be available to bounce from
this relationship at any moment yeah if
they're like I don't want to live on a
farm I'm like all right
that's a deal breaker yeah
hopefully none of you ladies like
running water
so Rachel specializes in that okay now
it's yellow can I ask you a little
racial how
how's what's the longest you've dated
someone
well that's not really important
I'm an expert after I wouldn't want to
make you feel okay
but uh it's six months six months yeah
that's like a lot longer than me I know
I'm like you're a Jedi pretty much
anyways are you guys excited to be
judged by two autistic people
hell yeah
we got some calculator [__] over
there
well we got some uh amazing contestants
in these buckets
no gays which should make you
comfortable
that question makes me uncomfortable uh
well I am wearing my feminist t-shirt
women's rights or human rights yeah okay
I'm wearing it ironically please don't
get too excited
and ridge is winning overalls so we'll
be playing Waldorf and whatever the
other guy's name was and what did you
face
what is that it's reference good cop bad
cop I feel like we're excited so close
together I like it
you never get this close together on the
farm unless you're about to touch
something
anyways we can move far apart and do
whatever you want
this is just how we're set but yes
um so for instance me the liberal I'd be
like hey you gotta and like walk her to
the door and open the car for her the
ridge would say something like
uh she can't open a car door herself
how she's supposed to throw a hay bale
so there look forward to that for the
rest of the video
are you guys ready for your first date
testance
let's get a straight man up straight
mail up here we got a man named Colton
oh he comes
this whole time
a man with a mustache
he is uh straight from the set of the
Wes Anderson movie
looks like he's comfortable on a
submarine
howdy how are you today Colton uh um
doing well looking to look
uh looking go looking to get into some
weird [__] hopefully these gals aren't
too light tight-lipped
I lift it lift he's gonna do some
unspeakable things yeah maybe we'll find
out I mean we'll speak them
that's good he's a very vocal guy
looking for a freak tonight that's what
you're you're looking for tonight and
yeah yeah for sure uh yeah like
I need somebody a little bit more
open-minded if you don't say it okay
we're looking for a non-traditional
yeah I need somebody who's open to the
fact that I'm married to a man
so
hopefully people are into that hopefully
it's a random poll is is is that right
yeah I mean sometimes you get gold
sometimes you get homophobia women
boy now yeah
yeah well anyways
um
women are here tonight anything you want
to say you said you're looking for a
freak somebody like Ringling Bros freak
like uh uh all right like a bearded
woman
yeah I love that you don't know who
Waldorf and whatever the other guy's
name is but you know the ring these Bros
like yeah I know circuses I just don't
know Sesame Street
they get cable they don't get basic TV
or they didn't get PBS now we have TV
hell yeah you just have the circus every
yeah
it's like the TV have you been in the
circus before no I haven't actually my
parents thought the circus was the devil
so we're never allowed going
the whole thing is the concept yeah just
like yeah it's
like I guess was the devil lurking in
the shadows or was he the circus
I I don't know I guess it was like the
just the cut the type of people
just like
yeah this those flexible women in the
freak shows were where's the devil
people who don't work with their hands
people who like to have fun and not
boring old Puritan work yep swallowing
swords and stuff
that's no way to make a living a real
Christian man
the only way to get closer to God is it
they have elephants and they don't even
use in the plow Fields like oh my God
they're like God's natural forklift in
God's natural God's natural Foreign
Fields either
I've never been there
I would have seen it on TV
all right very uh very practical ridges
about his elephant use he doesn't like
to use his elephants for frivolities
he wants to use them for important
things like war war and making God's
people full of corn anyways we've got
Anna valayak come on
going on a date with a gay man
can we get the lighting to can we get
the light or what it was before
I think that was better don't you think
so oh you could go up that way oh she's
an adventurer she's good on hikes all
right Annabelle going on with Colton for
90 seconds starting now
hi Anna you know so much about me uh
let's start with you okay are you are
you opened uh have you ever been to a
gay man before I haven't no no I can't
say I have are you sure
I think that's a good question uh maybe
the first man I was with what makes you
say that
[Music]
ah
I don't know he just
I don't know I don't know my brother's
gay I just feel like I have a little
Sixth Sense okay a little bit okay so
you're oh you know gay people yes where
are you from Chicago okay so you've been
to Boys Town I have yeah and you never
thought no those muscle bodies aren't
for me
no I I just haven't thought about it in
that way right honestly right because I
didn't think they were thinking about it
in that way no it's only a recent uh
thing for me too okay nice yeah yeah I
started Wellbutrin
okay yeah
yeah it's uh it's the whole thing yeah
yeah so just now like who tickles your
fancy someone on TV what like who who's
the who's the lady that
caught your eye maybe okay maybe it's a
little bit more far-fetched it's more of
a concept in my head okay where I'm
thinking what if I wasn't experiment to
you
yes okay but not this not Humanity I'm
not I'm not being like you're just a
hold of me but are you open to dirtier
talk and time give it up a Colton and
annabelleic
hey Anna I'm so sorry and I hope you get
a second date
I'm not you're not thinking to them in a
horrible way right that's good he's
speaking he's straight for the first
time in his life so he's might not be
good at it yeah that's not true I I
actually came out of the closet after
hair school
so I went to high school but then I came
out of the closet non-traditional ways I
think we've been waiting to get on the
stage like when you came up here you
were just
well you know those games in the theater
show
I I I do it is one of those things where
I think that I am open this idea to
strangers okay like the close my close
friends are like it's not no you're too
gay like I know Han's well enough where
he's like no
he's not [__] around with that you
know and by that I mean whole you know
uh so I want to know this idea up to
strangers where I could get some honest
feedback okay because I feel like I've
been in the gate hole too much so you're
just sussing this out right now yeah
okay aren't you married yes how long
have you been married for I'm not gonna
leave him
I know I know like I think everyone
figured that out at the beginning okay
when you said that this was like right
but we're not like gay people don't have
this crazy ownership like straight
people have like you guys are like and
if you [__] anyone else I'll kill myself
like gay people are like tell me about
it was it hot
like did they do the generalization
though a little bit right absolutely
which is why I'm bringing it to
strangers you know like are you two
together
cool
so you're saying straight people are
possessive Anna has there been a moment
where your significant other has been a
little too possessive
yeah yeah there has been how did that
turn out not good for him but why did
you leave him because of that
it's just some weird comments uh I think
he felt a little threatened by me or
something so yeah I feel like it tends
to be the guys that aren't open to it I
feel like the girls are like yeah we
could do it and then as soon as the guy
puts it with it [__] around
and find out yeah are you sure you're
not looking at people as holes yeah it
just feels like a very holy way to look
at people that's what that Lee Sam Smith
songs about oh he is gay
Sam Smith you don't know that song Holy
I don't know Sam Smith song Sorry I'm
more into Wiz Khalifa still like it and
Sara Bareilles are you looking to have a
Holy Night
um I guess I I'm kind of just you know I
I downloaded Tinder and it has been it
has been like a whole different
experience because you swipe you have to
ask questions that's not really gay
culture is not like that okay okay like
you just send a whole meet up time
what's your question about the gays are
you doing this are you doing this with
your husband like are you guys no no he
is not interested
no no no no like he's not interested in
your thought process and what you're
gonna do or like he's not interested in
also exploring that he's not interested
in exploring that what do you show with
you exploring it yeah that's very nice
how long have you guys been together
five years where are you from I'm an
army brat okay I'm a Navy brat okay go
army army baby yes this is it would
never work it would never work like for
more reasons but now this is all a
really good reason it's actually you
know it's actually all the things
you know pulling this apart or the
things that are going to keep us
together you know what I'm saying okay
yeah he's taking a lesson from straight
men never give up
even if it looks hopeless there's a way
to turn it around at the end you had a
question about gay people you could just
ask me privately I know
the question about gay people with
richers
so do you wear a condom or not no wait
when the person on the bottom does the
person are you asking me in general if
gay people use condoms no just the
bottom the bottom
the person female condom
no like on your dick on your dick just
so you don't get the sheets dirty
[__]
wow this is a new level of homophobia
has never seen before what would be the
benefit of that
sheets you know what I have to wash your
sheets okay no one is using condoms
mostly neither person sign me up how do
I turn gay as a one of the how do you
turn you you start by a little yeah I
guess pinky first pinky first
I mean been there done that really no
whoa he almost got excommunicated
what you should talk me and ridge yeah
you guys are figuring a lot of things
out right now I don't I I feel like I'm
helping him but I don't feel like I'm
learning anymore about my what turns out
to be maybe bisexuality or maybe it's
like you know just
a laugh came out of the closet what was
what was that like
bisexual feelings or no like you knew I
feel like I had repressed it so much
okay that I was like [__] for a whole
other reason it was to not be gay yeah
so now that I don't have that limitation
of like I better not be gay I'm more
open to like what if I connected with a
human this is Ridge in 20 years right
now yeah 20 years how old do you think
how old are you [__] I'm 32. okay how
old are you 23 23. okay
so is that good or bad I don't know
normally people have like a bigger
reaction to that I was waiting first
you're 23. no I feel like that's I mean
if you were a guy in 23 I'd be repulsed
okay uh why because they don't they
haven't had any perspective
they just have their stupid [__]
friends going yeah dude their whole
[__] life so you think women have
more perspective yeah because they've
been mean people have been mean to them
yeah girls are mean to girls that's true
they've had betrayals I have three older
brothers and grew up in a military
family so I feel like people have been
mean to me but yeah that's okay you're
around for being a woman though just for
murdering their family in Iraq
foreign
what is uh something that you've been
through as a woman that you don't think
most men would understand periods
how has that affected your life
personally there's a lot of pain
has it ever caused you to like call in
sick and not be able to go into school
or work
not really no if you had to explain to
Ridge what a period is
how would you use it like would it or
the feeling that you get just the
feeling just like the emotion from like
shooting pains in your stomach and you
just feel amazing in your mind kind of
like you have to take a [__] or
I don't know I've never held a [__] for
that long so I couldn't tell you
honestly but it sounds like you have so
I kind of got a [__] right now
wow okay that's a pickup line in
Pennsylvania
wait I want to go back to you though do
you feel like it's
is it like searching for something bad
okay so also one and a half years ago I
went to rehab okay so now I'm I'm
starting to feel feelings again you know
you know a lot of a lot of Bud Light a
lot of cocaine uh so now I'm like oh
what are these feelings maybe maybe
they're for love like you know Disney
movies
yeah yeah okay okay this is getting way
too gay for me right I'm kidding so uh
if you guys were to go on a date what do
you think it would look like do you guys
think it would be you know who would
foot the bill
I feel like I would have to foot the
bill I think that it would be weird that
my husband's name was on the credit card
but it'd be fine but it would be fine
and you know
I wouldn't look I promise I put the bill
I don't mean your husband Bill put a
foot in his ass I mean uh paid for the
dinner no one thought you meant that
Hans well if they did there would be a
comedic genius yeah right because my
name my husband's name is Champ chip
chip
it's a nickname for every hoof trimmer
on the farm chip a what a hoof trimmer a
trim cow's feet yeah
foot the chip yeah okay I feel like I
would have to do a lot at this point if
we're going on a second date I'm gonna
have to prove to her that I don't just
see her as a whole I probably have to so
like we'd have to probably do like uh I
I'm I'm usually not the one who plans
the dates so it seems like she's very
fascinated in your lifestyle and she's
very intrigued intellectually what uh
what is what are you most curious about
Colton's you know sudden change of heart
um
a lot a lot I think it's interesting
definitely uh I'm more interested in the
motivation behind it I guess but now I
feel like holes heard heard uh different
holes yeah have you ever had a bisexual
or any urges in that direction I have it
no you never went with the women no did
you go to college
I did oh it's not a good time you went
to college too probably a community
college no I went to college I had Gay
Thoughts yeah you had Gay Thoughts yeah
it's College yeah if you're not out
there reading books what are you doing
you know working
okay and what do you do for work now
working Tech of course doing
client success it's a new job client
success yeah okay client success I don't
really I haven't prepared my elements
what does that mean yeah for it I just I
just got the job so it's like I'm not
well let's try to get her fired
they're here so you you can oh nice
wow are you on a date no uh
with her co-workers
you don't date your co-workers no you're
a hair stylist
I did as soon as I came out I was like
oh I don't want to care what do you do
now
pardon what do you do now uh I'm a
writer
oh I studied creative writing in college
what do you what do you write about uh
I'm uh for it's a Pac a political action
committee and we just write Greg Abbott
jokes
um can we hear one okay
can we hear a Greg Abbott joke what was
your most recent
[Music]
Greg Abbott's tough on the border but
what does he stand for
whoa that's able that's a staunch
feminist I have to criticize the ableism
in that joke but as a liberal I gotta
hand it to you really [__] over the
cons
you own the cons on that one yeah so you
know you guys look like if you combined
your outfits you could be a prisoner
that's what I was going for a mime you
look like a French mime
you guys you guys both have blue eyes it
is interesting that you're representing
very much navy colors and I've gone yeah
it shows our divide definitely that's
that's our divide right there that wall
yeah yeah
symbolism
so what's your biggest problem with my
situation
like like for real though I need I need
some honest like what like if this was
real and I was like let's go on a second
date why is your brain saying no don't
do it
I don't think I would have anything to
lose to go on a second date with you
because I know that probably there's not
much of of an outcome for me if you're
going to stay married so okay whatever
is like the side chick the entire time
so that's why you're interested in it
there's nothing to lose no she's not gay
that's only exciting to gay people the
polyamory yes no it's great what's
happening I know it's multiple lovers oh
no
not like the Mormons
yeah
yeah I mean it's multiple people I mean
you're having trouble with one I don't
think you're ready for polyamory yet
maybe when you get to three weeks
are you talking to me yeah yeah I think
it's talking to you he's talking to me
yeah he's married he's been in a
relationship forever
yeah yeah I finally I did the one now
I'm upgrading it too you know yeah wow
how long have you guys been married two
years okay
what was your wedding like
it was the pandemic wedding was it over
Zoom
we no we didn't what okay we didn't we
didn't feign that there was some like
priest being like in God's school with
this one
no he's cool with this one uh God was
like and amen
so no wait like what do you so why would
we have a ceremony so you don't have a
ceremony why would we have it I was just
wondering I'm curious it didn't seem
like they're we're gonna have a party
still is the idea but we just we just
don't really see any benefit to it
okay very non-traditional
[Music]
man I don't know I just don't like why
why do all that
why do you want that why do you want me
to have that I just I don't know I'm
curious okay I just have a happy day
yeah a day that you call it like oh if
you ever bought yourself an eight ball
and
that whole day is about you you know
what I'm saying
I've had a several special days
Anna have you ever had an eight ball
before
no no okay so you mostly stick with weed
and heroin
just just weed oh stoner not really
gateway drug
I definitively not I don't like wheat
you don't like weed no well maybe Colton
can be your gateway drug into gays that
could be your other thing do you see any
red flags
a few
Colton what about you do you see any red
flags yeah I do like she's she's a
little scared
that's true but you did put your name in
The Bucket
I did not whoa who signed you up so
somebody else set you on a date with a
gay man
apparently who is it God
come on up here I guess he was angry
that I got married to a dude
he doesn't come up he's just always
around I feel like the red flags I have
are like I feel like we would have to be
breaking the barriers together you know
and I feel like right lots of work and I
feel like just getting to know each
other is hard enough I feel like
you know she started a new job she's not
really looking to tie events you know to
breaking social barriers
so you're tender you you're swiping on
women yeah okay so Tinder was the place
you first looked for a real connection
that was where you looked no second
place no no I mean it's expectations but
like if you're not on Tinder where are
you
not on Tinder where are you you don't
even exist you're on a date with a gay
dude
like which was better yeah that never
happens on Tinder
it's a great point right I feel like you
just you cast a bunch of hooks and
sometimes what's your pickup line what's
my pickup line on Tinder like are you
introducing the situation up front or
you're just playing it cool
anybody who's presenting all their
baggage at once is a huge [__] red
flag
but you know I didn't want to you know
anyways
um so yeah you guys are the wrong
orientation but we're working out all
right so what do you think uh is like
your favorite
sport
it's football hell yeah yeah the game is
going on right now none of us like
football
yeah how about you Anna soccer
no communists
cool I don't know it's your favorite
sport Hans
probably uh
probably something really equally uh uh
you know uh favorable to women like uh
figure skating
[Music]
[Laughter]
rhythmic gymnastics
because I'm a feminist okay
um but anyways rugby is amazing you
should watch it women's rugby did you
recently get into it no
yeah
it's not a reasonably cool I've always
loved that all right
uh uh I'll figure my [__] out we'll go
on another day I'll let you know okay
give it up for Colton and Anna
[Applause]
all right let's get a actual straight
man up here that's usually better
because they're [__] [__] uh we
got Andy and uh here he is
a very smart looking man
probably has an extensive DVD collection
get up for Andy
key boss and neighborly hi Hans hi Rich
did you call me [__] immediately I
said men are [__] which as a
feminist is very pretty
obvious
um Andy how's the uh old submarine with
Colton with the
I don't know I thought I would be on the
same subject how's uh Austin going
keeping it weird and all that neighborly
neighborly what neighborhood uh I live
by the capitol oh it's a good
neighborhood yeah I got pretty lucky I
just kind of moved from uh Florida and
I was looking for a place to stay this
is an interesting world to keep it short
but there was someone lined up to move
in and he wanted to cook with drugs in
the food some weird thing but the guy I
was moving in with was a pharmacist
pharmacist so he said I can't have you
cook with drugs in the food is it weed
yeah probably maybe other things I don't
know what but usually it's weird so the
very low bar I had to clear was not
wanting to cook with wheat or drugs in
the in my uh what a good roommate you
are
past the very low bar you came from
Florida you're like let me get as close
to something I'm familiar with we've
moved in right next to Governor Abbott
right right
are DeSantis
Rich do you have any questions for Andy
he lives right by the capitol
nah
he just respects your good American
patriotism
um maybe I should ask you guys questions
nope okay
so that's cool who are you looking for
on on this day are you single
um no okay honest people aren't yeah
that come on this show for some reason
I figured it'd be fun to throw my name
in the Hat and embarrass myself also are
you in a relationship with Colton by
chance uh no is your name chip no
it's not chip are you heterosexual yes
thank you we'll take it
a straight man in a relationship
how long
um about a year
nice one year wow it's really long it's
like a [__] marriage for Ridge
this is two weakers
um yeah Ridge is uh you know got a lot
of questions for you I'm sure
um but yeah I'm just staring at you guys
I'm sorry I'm not as a communicative as
a Colton Colton's really good at just
communicate with that part if you're
gonna communicate anything don't
communicate that you don't communicate
true
um
but yeah I love that uh you know you
live by the Capitol and you have a sense
of fashion I could I could tell you more
about me or you want to know more than
just where I live
um yeah
yeah
totally
um why don't I uh start with what I do
I'm a college shooter I tutor UT
students I run my own Tutoring company
okay you're a tutor
tutor tutor or just tutor just tutor you
ever been to tutors
no tutors yeah it's a West Virginia
chain it's like Waffle House oh okay oh
no no oh yeah we have plenty of those in
Florida everything sounds racist coming
out of here
you ever seen one of those tutors
anyways uh yeah you uh you're looking
for a date is it just yeah for fun just
for fun okay well let's see Alyssa
coming up to the stage
Alyssa
here she comes from the back
[Applause]
oh we gotta get the person I signed Anna
up to come up here that's the rule if
you sign someone else up you gotta come
up so that person's coming up next get
up for Alyssa
and Andy going on a date for 90 seconds
starting now okay Andy what do you do
for your girlfriend why hasn't she
dumped you yet uh I try to make her feel
cared about and special and I make sure
her days are made easier by me I guess
foot rubs cunnilingus what's your
specialty uh a little bit of column a
little bit of column B okay okay uh
what's the nicest thing you can tell me
about your mom
um
she's a hard-working entrep well was
she's no longer with us but she was a
hard-working entrepreneur she definitely
uh
started her own business and I thought
that was admirable excellent okay so you
love your mom I do awesome that's
[__] dope okay what else what would
you make me for dinner tonight uh I like
making gnocchi
beautiful yeah from from scratch and
it's pretty easy yeah because it's just
potatoes and flour and egg oh and then
what kind of sauce would we uh like a
pesto is what I usually go with I like
to cook a lot so okay uh but if if
that's not your thing I can do something
no I love pesto I love gnocchi but do
you make your own pesto too I don't make
my own pesto I just store bought I don't
go the whole I don't know I don't know
it's like a store-bought passed out I
don't know well wait is there not like
uh is there something wrong with
store-bought pesto or no there's mainly
something wrong with the bag that you're
taking
um okay let's see I have other questions
and then I'll let you go um let's see
with uh what was it oh my stomach hurts
what would you do if I told you how bad
my stomach hurt
it makes me think lucky Rich because I
think he would just tell you to take a
[__] just go take a [__] okay but no I I
um what would I do if your stomach hurt
um I was like complaining we were out
somewhere I was like my tummy hurts like
how would you deal with that yeah that's
that's tough because I can't really do
anything about it
um do you want I would say if we're out
you're saying roundabout I would say
like do you want to just go home and lay
down and rest okay Bitters and soda next
time she asks okay
fine she'll stop whining and time give
it up for Alyssa giving out medical
advice
women need to be taken care of with soda
and lime or whatever
and Andy wow really showing us your
worth your very good boyfriend you
listened you answered the question you
looked a little scared the whole time
doing it I'm terrified I'm a deer in
headlights right now
what's the biggest fight you got into
with your girlfriend
uh
uh uh well no that one
that that
I'm gonna I'll just
lay it all out there
um are you gay no but uh no
um
so we had friends over and uh they were
having sex and we were an entire house
yeah yeah
um not or not hey ask her do they ask
permission we're like hey yes oh yeah it
was kind of like a kind of a swinging
thing what the [__] everyone's having
sex but I don't just see the people as
holes like it's terrible I shouldn't
have sex till you're married
were they married uh no oh yeah so the
fact that I guess to answer your
question the fight was I think I said
something like I guess she told me that
she wasn't feeling well not I don't know
if a stomach ache or whatnot I should
have just said Bitters and lime and soda
but um I think I kind of
I guess I I think I she was mad at me
for speaking for her so I think I might
have said something to the effect of
like telling them that maybe they should
leave and
because I I don't know I just thought
she was feeling bad so I told
how do you tell people having sex
so it was it was I don't know if I'm
interrupting
you want an actual answer
yes uh yeah uh
I just they had were taking a break so
that I found that an opportune time to
chime in and say
um hey I don't know you know she's not
feeling great so
um if you want to continue this at home
or even in a car yeah sure right yeah so
you came in during halftime yes and then
I kind of and then the argument the
biggest fight was and honestly probably
her only fight
um was because she was mad that I spoke
for her she because she didn't say
specifically that because she didn't
want them there but I thought that that
was the best course of action and she
was like don't don't speak for me yeah
because you kicked the a couple out that
was having sex yeah that doesn't sound
that bad
maybe that's mad that you guys weren't
having fun and they were yeah and then
she wanted to I don't know I don't know
I think she was gonna rally and then she
wanted her friends to stay so
so you thought she was uncomfortable but
she wasn't yes correct
she just wanted to [__] yes
I think she was I think she was in a
watching mood oh okay okay a watching a
watching mood what watching mood so you
tried to [__] her and then she said her
tummy hurt no no no no no no no she she
was in what what well uh no okay okay
whatever I think she was just you're not
available but is there anything you'd
like to know about me oh yeah sure um
do something in quirky do you like uh so
do you have a dishwash do you use a
dishwasher I I do have a dishwasher I
usually just wash my dishes but by hand
yeah okay because I was gonna say if you
do use dishwasher you are prongs up like
the food end of the utensil up in the
dishwasher or prong into down prong down
but I've gotten a lot of trouble with
roommates for like I just don't use the
dishwasher no I mean well what's wrong
they don't they don't like it that you
hand wash no no not currently uh no they
they love that I hand wash I I just
don't I didn't grow up with a dishwasher
so I always just wash my dishes after I
cook a meal and
um you didn't grow up with a mom a
dishwasher yeah oh wow wow he's from the
country no my mom isn't a little [__]
and she made me do my dishes you know
um um what one word represents what you
want most in a romantic relationship
I'll allow two words if you want to uh
put an adjective in there I guess
consider it
that's the that's what I use that's the
answer I usually give consideration yeah
consideration intelligence ideally
they're funny and they have a nice sized
dick uh yeah nice size dick that's three
what size would that be just you know
average is great for me I'm a small lady
I'm average yeah yeah solid average yeah
Alyssa have you been on lots of dates
with uh men that are in relationships uh
no no I do not do that if I find out
they're with somebody I just leave uh I
don't like doing that I feel like uh
women should probably try not to do that
like if I've met their wife and she said
I give you my blessing I never want to
suck this man's dick again then fine but
unless I get the blessing of the partner
and even in those situations it just
gets weird because now you're like in
the middle of this thing I don't like
being in the middle I would [__] Colton
and his husband before I would [__] a
straight guy who has a partner yeah
because straight people are weird too me
too would you ever have uh
yeah yeah actually that's kind of why I
wish I had had that date because I'm
like Colton I would do this like can
your husband watch like this is a very
beautiful man this is so hot right
um good looking yes would you ever have
sex with some with your partner in
someone else's home I've definitely done
that yeah
happen how does that usually people
are like hey like you guys want a [__]
in our bed I don't know when I was
dating a woman I got everybody gave us
the bedroom anytime people like that
more than a man [__] a woman in their
home well I was like a crime I mean
anyways uh Andy what's your favorite
thing about dating in Austin
um
I would say I don't know
off top of my head I would just say
people are pretty outgoing people hobby
oriented vivacious
what vivacious definition yeah uh Lively
oh okay full of life yeah
that's cool I mean as opposed to I don't
know I I can't say I mean I've never
been to New York or some maybe colder
places where people are just I don't
know
I don't know more I don't know harder
colder so yeah is that a lot of
alternative relationships in Austin
where people are [__] in your home
and uh gay guys and stuff what was the
question are there a lot of
alternatively minded folks yeah for sure
okay cool
uh Alyssa what are you looking for in a
man besides single
[Laughter]
type again bridge is out yeah
I can't read yeah you can't read
especially can't read a blood type
did you say blood type yeah
uh I I always just think it's a funny
thing like if he's ever in if there's an
emergency right and the guy is bleeding
out and he doesn't know his blood type
then he deserves to bleed out I'm just
gonna let it let him die it's not my
fault
um no I just I think it's a silly
question and it throws people off what's
your blood type I'm an O Negative oh is
that a universal donor yeah I give her
uh yeah but I don't do it okay I don't
do it I smoke too much weed I did DMT
last weekend I don't want to hurt the
people you know I think people would pay
extra money for that blood
are you are you seeing anybody uh I'm
dating probably like four different
people currently yeah is there one who's
like leading me
what is going on
I I haven't slept with any of them I
just have been letting them take me out
and I'm kind of spilling it out and like
one of them is better at cuddling and
the other one's a little bit smarter and
there's one who's kind of really hot and
then there's the one that I really like
and uh you're the one that you like or
good at cuddling or
he's good at all those things but we are
currently it's a friendship it's a
friendship and I don't know so if you
have any advice what should I do because
normally I would just jump on them but
I'm trying to be more feminine and um so
like if you guys have any like ways that
I could hint to this yeah there's not a
lot of jumping and femininity have you
seen the WNBA
literally I'm just I'm trying not to be
like the aggressor all the time anymore
because normally it would just be like
you let's [__] I have a really great bed
and that would work but now I'm like you
know I have a really great bed I want
what kind of bed is it a dream Cloud
it's like it's not it's really not it's
really nice
um it's just got a lot of resistance you
know it's like perfect for all kinds of
activities but I just what other
activities Oh well
what were you thinking you said all
kinds well I mean there's just what
other activities on a bed jumping
jumping it's great for jumping you have
a high ceiling there I'm short so I do
actually have a really high ceiling yeah
I thought you would try not to jump
so like you know I'm just wondering like
what do I say did you say pound like
pounce pounce on them uh so I'm trying
not to pounce on people anymore
you got a bet that's perfect for
pouncing I'm I actually ever since I got
this new bed I haven't had sex the bed
is so nice
that I'm rethinking my whole life so
that pickup line doesn't work not
anymore
is there a among the four guys you're
dating is there a front runner yes no I
think they're all losing and that's why
I'm dating all of them and uh yeah and
that's why I have a crush on my friend
uh and uh yeah no thank you is your
friend here no okay no but yeah they're
all very nice and like I've dated a lot
of hot dangerous guys in my life so I'm
also trying to see what really nice guys
are like like not criminals
um it was like a dangerous hot dangerous
guy you dated to be like motorcycle
felon oh definitely had the motorcycle
boyfriends I don't know how many of them
um what about a moped boyfriend never
done a moped boyfriend but you know I do
have a nicer version of a motorcycle
it's like slightly there's still some
danger but we can only get up to like
what 50 miles per hour yeah I went a lot
faster
um yeah I'm ready to slow down you know
I'm ready to just kind of slow down
moped boyfriend I would probably give it
a try you know I'm saying yes that's why
I'm dating four guys right now you know
I just said yes to every do they know
about each other uh it's none of their
[__] business
so yes
they know by your attitude and how you
disrespect them in public
but but I mean I'm not gonna ask them if
they're I'm assuming that unless we have
a conversation about monogamy and the
state of our relationship that we're
doing whatever we want to do and if you
want to share with me what you're doing
I mean I'm assuming I'm probably getting
more action than all of them because
they're very nice
guys don't get laid according to Alyssa
no I'm not saying that
it's a nice guy move right there yeah
you can have sex no one else is having
sex in here anyways
is your girlfriend here no oh damn it I
was gonna be like hi you know like
what's up this is never gonna work don't
worry about it
Andy what's the most number of people
that you've ever dated
uh dated I like like have been in
relationships with her just at the same
time I have candidates
candidates and taking job applications
20 10 20. 20 in one time one time I'm
confused you thought I thought you just
said it ever in the list of the
situation she's dating what about you I
probably have gone on dates with poor
guys two or two to three two or three
yeah
you sound like Ridge
dude your figure out you should be
dating other people I'm just going to
assume you're dating other people that's
none of my business if we start thinking
we're serious we can have a conversation
like adults but these guys are like oh
my God but I really like you and I'm
like I don't care we don't know each
other go with that lady she's nice maybe
that's the problem with with why I'm
still single yeah no but yes fine fine
she's too permissive and open to other
people I think that's very mature you
know I think that's how you date in 2023
yeah after a month I'll talk to these
guys I'll be like okay I [__] another
current status or anything you can just
like get to know people yeah
um
do you have any real controversial
opinions at all like uh I'm not gonna
suggest any that's gonna
well yeah suggest something let's see
because I do have really controversial
abortion um I think abortion is really
bad
um I think it's terrible uh but I think
well I love it yeah I think abortion I
think abortion sucks but it's just such
a good experience and it's and let me
tell you necessary evil because I'm a
man yeah I'm pro-life and I'm pro-choice
like obviously it's not a great choice
but it should be a choice right right
it's a shitty Choice have you had an
abortion I have oh wait is that
something you don't answer yeah I don't
think you asked that okay bad question
yeah
it's been balling up here it's all right
yeah yeah uh well you want to hang out
later oh me yeah I'll come over for sure
yeah wait you're not bringing anybody
else over are you I don't know maybe
would you like to talk further about
this abortion or would you no no I've
had one guys I have had hey give it up
for Alyssa she had an abortion thank you
thank you thank you she's a liberal
ish
so anyways let's get away from
controversial subjects you got 90
seconds to ask her questions now it's
our turn Rich any questions for Alyssa
or Andy
oh Andy you asked me to hang out later
yeah yeah
oh you can ask it what are you cooking
uh tonight
uh I have chili that I made chili yeah
nice it's kind of chilly outside
yes it is there you go that's why I made
it some Pennsylvania jokes
um that's cool uh is that a good snack
for Bros to just eat chili
peppers
yeah watch some football no ladies
allowed it's the fart zone now
Alyssa what's your favorite snack to eat
on a date
snack as a date snack
do you bring like little orange slices
pistachios no I don't I know I would
probably you know stash pistachios it's
not allergic to nuts not at all no none
of them um
but uh dates snack yeah I don't know
probably him if I was happy you know oh
yeah date snack if I don't know I feel
like that take someone down a few eyes
in my I don't know at bringing a date
snack I mean I always have snacks I'm a
little person so I always have nuts in
the car usually pistachios but like
that's a what's their favorite uh the
freaky thing to do with a date freaky
thing right now yeah uh
I I mean I don't know of my favorite I'm
not really a fetishist like I'm I
probably will say yes if I'm if it
sounds fun you know like I'll try
anything once or three times but I don't
know I don't have any like specific
fetishes like hey you want to [__] me on
the roof of the city hall again what's
something else that's right once have
you done that yeah what's something you
only tried once something I only tried
once no you've only yeah yeah
something you have only tried once
I don't know I probably tried it all
twice I slept with multiple men at the
same time multiple times I slept with
multiple women at the same time multiple
I mean anal I tried that multiple times
you know it's not my favorite but it can
be great uh blow jobs done that like
four times you know
um just a total of four times you know
you've only given four blow jobs total I
thought you liked nuts
you kind of look like that brave brave
Brave oh I've gotten that before yeah
but yeah this is this cartoon a cartoon
character this is ridge's first time
seeing a feminist in real life yeah
you're a feminist no I mean I'm a woman
I'm a woman for sure I you're a woman
typically just tell people I'm a [__]
but yeah feminist Works whoa Why Not Bow
why not both you don't think feminists
can be [__] too anything is possible
now it's 20 23.
um Andy are you a feminist or do you
just dress like that
is this is this place a feminist
definitely okay yeah I'm a feminist oh
yeah what's your most feminist quality
um like on a date
um probably going like to answer an
earlier question kind of going dutch on
the date Dutch oh split I don't do that
no they have to pay they have to pay
families [__] I know that some
people I mean it depends I honestly
actually I'll probably say it probably
depends on the situation like if there's
somebody who's so that's the most
important lesson you got from feminism
is make the woman pay
wait that just that just says that
they're equal right or you're treating
them as they're equal right yeah you're
equal pay for your [__] dinner
I'm not paying for your [__] we make the
same amount of money depend yeah I was
gonna say it probably depends on whether
or not they're uh making the same amount
right if there's somebody who is so so
you're like pay for dinner you're like
the resources thing so I so if somebody
is like oh if it's a matter of like and
also I think that there's something to
be said for if you're the one who asked
someone out on a date maybe you do opt
to agree agree if I ask a guy out then
I'm either making dinner or we're
getting burritos if he asked me out he's
definitely paying I will not go dutch I
don't do it I would say it's situation
dependent but I I don't it depends on
many different factors okay that's kind
of nice I guess to women
um so you you hate that you hate going
dutch you just want you just want
someone to pay or there's got a person
I'm just assuming if you can't buy me
dinner someone else can and if I like
you asked me and if I like I said if I
asked you I've made men dinner plenty of
times I bought men dinner plenty of
times in my life I'm not against it but
if I ask you out then I'm gonna be like
hey you wanna or if they want to go
dutch with me I'm straight up we're
going to burritos like and then I'm not
gonna there's not even a chance I'm
gonna [__] you like and that's that's
how she keeps so fit
she just doesn't eat unless someone's
paying for it do you play video games
yeah
what's your favorite video game I know
um
uh it's a board game but I've been
playing it on my PC it's called
terraforming Mars cool yeah he's an Elon
Musk fan no are are those your uh some
of those are my friends we'll see if
they're still my friends after this
oh [__] you work at the uh I don't
actually what there are friends and then
there are uh co-workers of those friends
okay
we work with them so who do you who and
they may also be friends too I don't
know so who do you not like the most uh
Ariel Ariel Ariel I'm kidding what do
you not like about it the reason I said
that is because I like him the most but
uh oh
so good at this
um
what's that
what
nothing which one oh Ariel it was a
movie joke oh wait I don't know that
Alyssa what is your favorite movie
favorite movie what's your favorite
color
I don't have a favorite color I don't
have a favorite movie
what's your favorite tell us more about
like something that you hate on a date
that was that was interesting I hate on
a date
um
oh God uh the hate boring people I hate
boring people uh I hate if they're rude
to any like service people that's like
duh uh don't be a dick in general
um but yeah they're not adventurous like
I went on a date to Chez Panisse very
nice restaurant maybe some of you guys
but it's fancy as [__] right it's
delicious and my date scraped the sauce
off the fish oh and uh yeah that was
over it was over it was over I was like
you this is the nicest restaurant I was
so embarrassed and I was like okay now
you're just gonna eat boring plain fit
like these these are Pros back here okay
they're making this is the BET like
anyway I was just so annoyed I didn't
look at him the rest of the night and
then I just said I don't feel like doing
this anymore so picky eaters is like a
if you scrape juices off fish you can't
it was a beautiful Bechamel probably
something delicious
no it's just what are you doing why did
we even go to a nice restaurant I could
have eaten here by myself and not had to
watch a child scrape so like what are
you doing he doesn't experience the
culinary arts like you do yeah like
little boys yeah I'm not gonna go out
with them again you should watch the
movie The Menu I feel like that you'd
relate to oh maybe yeah a guy that hates
people and kills them yeah
anybody I'm just not gonna go out with
them
if you killed anything or no except
maybe ants I used to eat them when I was
a little girl you're an anteater I would
eat you know like your kids I lived in
the country you eat bugs sometimes
something you do yeah I eat caterpillars
gotcha Yeah I broke out in hives I don't
know yeah my tongue swelled up and so
let's get another couple up here yeah
yeah
it's got a woman up here first nice
Amber
Amber Amber coming on to the stage Amber
no movement movement sound like a strip
club
Amber is this Amber coming up hell yeah
here she comes give it up for Amber
[Applause]
so what do you what are you learning so
far seeing these two couples uh these
two couples I'm learning a lot they're
very interesting couples not
um not normal not regular not regular
people
hello Amber how are you tonight
I
think we will
you look like you could hurt our
feelings
you got that right what's the uh
craziest thing that's happened to you on
a date
[Music]
have you ever had to roast someone on a
date
to run out you know just kind of
escaping oh what was the last thing you
said before you escaped you had to
escape I'll be right back yeah
and then you just so you lied
well hopefully you won't say that
tonight because we got a very lovely
gentleman that randomly signed up in a
bucket so that's our vetting process
we got a very beautiful man named Jovan
of zali
here he comes he's ready for his big
moments
coming on up here on a Brisk Pace give
it up for Jovan going on a date for 90
seconds with Amber starting now yeah I'm
of 21 so this is gonna be weird
um wait can I ask you a question though
can I ask you a question cougar
um
that's is that hot I don't know what it
is
What's um what's so what's the worst
thing you've ever done to a human being
you think
back to jail oh
okay uh one time I peed on my what about
the third worst thing ever to do oh my
grandpa said on accident I was peeing
out a window and it landed on but that
was probably like I felt really bad yeah
hahaha
sorry this is like my biggest fears are
like public speaking and talking to
girls so this is bad just think of me
of Me no
[Laughter]
what's for dinner uh you know
um do you uh do you have hobbies or
something
what do you mean a ball
oh that's cool all the old people stuff
okay I like old people stuff I uh one
time I met a girl at Bingo and we uh we
hung out for like three hours and we
went to a Denny's and it was cool oh
okay yeah well maybe you're out of my
age range then I don't know yeah
yeah
I um I don't know you seem like a nice
lady you have a good smile are you sling
yeah I'm single yeah are you single yeah
nice how long have you been how long
have you been single for
eign
[Music]
person like that
no okay okay uh are you from here no I'm
not from here uh me either where are you
from Tennessee oh [__] is uh you like it
better here I'm just visiting okay for
my birthday oh oh [__] I didn't have
anything oh end time my sister bought me
for my birthday to Austin well thank you
for coming to Austin give it up for
Amber it's her birthday
she's in Austin
home of the weirdos
and Jovan 21 year old lothario look at
those beautiful locks of hair thanks
yeah Jovan why did you open with I'm 21.
because it I wanted to know that it
probably wouldn't work out but I still
like her as a person well just try to
keep that Under Wraps until all right I
know for sure
wait what's your credit score because
actually that's like a big factor for me
dude yeah I have six percent Jewish so
yeah writing it out I got like a I got
like a 732 last time I checked oh okay
what's your what's yours okay well thank
you all right um how embarrassing as a
Jew
Jovan uh amber told you that you can
think of me as your mom how hard did you
come
when she said that I didn't I didn't
nothing really happened inside of me
really you're a Jewish Man Without a
weird complex about his mother no not
really I don't know that's not
believable I mean like what like what
like do most people get hard when they
think of their mom I don't know Jewish
men no hope not yeah that's why I
thought that was normal that's why it
was a joke
I don't have a good sense of humor so
that's why well don't say that either
try to say that you're 28 and you have a
great sense of humor that's just a
little keys to dating I think I think
that's good tips Amber have you ever uh
been a cougar to someone younger than
you before
what is the biggest like weird thing
that happened because he was so young it
went weird they enjoyed it oh [__] it
wasn't weird Jovan how does that make
you feel
um a little intimidated and excited at
the same time
I just feel like you excel in that zone
I'm sorry what nope nothing I'm sorry
um Jovan so what is like your favorite
activity to do I like to
um uh I like playing the chess a lot
lately and I also have been uh trying to
like brush my teeth more like doing
hygiene
he brushes his teeth Amber this guy's
quite a catch well and other hygienic
stuff like uh like I use this tongue
scraper you guys are like a tongue
scraper that stuff it's weird you're
like a scraper yeah you got like this
weird like dead it's almost looks like
cheese that just comes off your tongue
and it's like
oh no well you're shaking your head try
to say things that'll get you laid I
like uh yeah oh I got a clean tongue I
feel like that's sexual as hell yeah
now when you say it looks like cheese
curds well that's what came off now it's
nice and really ready to go yeah can we
see it
hello oh look at that time
looks like the color of your sweater
wait are these guys a little Annoying to
you too
wait what Jovan you're on the show that
you signed up for all right no I was
just trying to connect with my date and
like
enemies you had 90 seconds and you
totally [__] it up
oh who signed you up
I don't know you know
oh wow that means you're going on a date
with Jovan right now
Jovan have you ever dated a man before
no I never actually yeah
um well you're only 21. yeah sure enough
I guess yeah I um I don't know if if a
day can't I went go-karting with this
dude once and he said I had nice back
pockets but that's the only thing like a
closest thing I ever had to a date
I was a dude trying to [__] you yeah I
think so back pockets yeah you have in
there nothing I think he's just trying
to say I had a nice ass but I think he's
lying I don't know because it's kind of
a weird way to say that huh yeah you
should just
your pockets he doesn't have any
sweatpants
Amber what's your trick to seduce
younger guys they're pretty easy but
they can't I mean they come
in more ways than one
[Laughter]
you know they got a lot of spunk built
up in them not me actually I um I'm like
addicted to pornography so I don't
really come though Jovan I'm trying to
get you laid right now [__] it up I'm
just let me interrupt to make myself
look even less sexy than I already did
yeah yeah
try to say what's a positive thing about
yourself sorry I um
I care about uh other people sometimes
yeah you care about other people
sometimes yeah like yeah most of the
most humanitarian a philanthropist in
our events I also uh yeah I like um
I like treat homeless people with
respect to I don't know if that's a good
sign but like some dude I got your
grandpa oh no he's walking below you oh
yeah I'll get you some too yeah please
women like bad boys okay so I should be
again okay yeah um you have a little
roughness
yeah there you go yeah shut up
is this a good character I should do
from now yes
that's the posture of a dude that pees
on his grandpa
um
that's a good position to be able to pee
on yourself
all right
yeah anyways
Amber what's the uh
what's the kind of guys that you usually
are looking at
I mean I like nice bodies
nice face you know because if they got
the beer belly you can't
do it yeah I have a bad body yeah so
sometimes oh my God some girls once dude
I have like weird because it's like like
wear baggy clothes so I look thinner but
yeah if I have it's gross dude yeah
you're only 21. I don't see me muscles I
like our muscles she's looking at a
particular man oh these guys yeah Jovan
I want you to your impression of that
guy right there okay and talk to Amber
and tell her about your day today
[Laughter]
you like you like it don't you
uh you think it's sexy when I condition
my chest hair or oh all right I won't do
that then
what up ladies man yeah I love the
sudden change that we've seen in you I
won't do that sorry
he's trying he's trying yeah so have you
been on a date before yeah yeah I took a
girl to a buffet like last week it
wasn't romantic at all but which Buffet
uh I don't know some Chinese buffet I'm
not and it was uh it was it wasn't even
around here it was in Denver too did you
pay yeah I paid dude hell yeah how much
was it like 20 bucks it was uh I think
like 17.
did you get soda or not she did I let
her I got water wow go on a date with
Jovan he'll let you get soda yeah what
kind of soda did she get she would do
which she got a Diet Coke I don't know
that seems that seems pretty normal I
just don't believe like I feel like Diet
it's like you're still being a fat [__]
just give up yeah and when did you say
that during the date
I said it in my head I'm yeah I I wasn't
really honest on that date sometimes I
do that on dates it's like I'll just
like kind of sit there and be agreeable
which is not always the best tactic I
think no yeah so what's the what what's
like what do you do besides that or do
you sometimes like oh no I disagree with
you oh yeah sometimes I'll like I'll be
like oh [__] I'm being too agreeable and
then I'll just disagree with everything
she says and that's also bad she'll be
like oh I want to have sex with you I'm
like you're dumb yeah
why he's still single yeah
Amber what's the uh what's the what's
the kind of dates that you like to go on
do you like to go dinner dates or
I like to go bowling
if they're you know as long as it's not
what if you go on a different phase you
said you said bowling yeah what's your
score like what's a do you blow a lot or
not
like are you good at bowling well I used
to be oh okay I love you have your own
ball
yeah oh three
these things are heavy
if you go on a date with her and she has
experience keeping balls in bags
so what happens if you go on a date with
a dude and he's bad at bowling does it
turn you off a little bit
no I mean I'm competitive so so you're
like yes an easy target yeah wait I
thought of a joke actually what if I use
like the bumpers because it's like the
condoms of bowling or something no all
right bumpers are the condoms of bowling
Jovan
Jovan what's some other Pearls of Wisdom
that you've noticed um I'm only 21
that's all I really got yeah it's mostly
bowling based humor uh I guess what this
is the goal uh yeah no that's all yeah
I don't know what you just said oh I was
gonna say like like three dollars is the
way you want to be treated but I think I
just read that on a poster I don't even
really believe it yeah what what weight
are the balls
what weight are they 12 they're 12. wow
yeah
is there those are heavy
Siobhan was 12.
she just lift your breasts up
[Music]
oh yeah
what's your uh favorite food
well I just well for the last two years
I stopped eating meat so oh [__] oh yeah
but um I like desserts
I can't I can't I can't do that dude
yeah wait you want someone that eats
meat yeah I think I like carnivorous
[__] oh we got Colton coming on up
and Colton back
well that's fun uh what's your hobbies
besides scraping your tongue
um I uh I was lost I was thinking about
picking up fishing today does anyone
like that I feel like it could be fun I
don't know fishing yeah yeah that guy
likes yeah yeah nice um went to Walmart
and I realized it's kind of expensive so
I just said [__] it I'll use my hands or
maybe just never do it yeah is this I
don't think it's that expensive like you
can get a nice rod for 40 bucks
what the [__] you think expensive
he's 20. it's like you see a dude in
sweatpants you think I just got 40
something that's like I knew I gotta
save my Buffet money I don't know what
the [__] you thinking
I should give this man yeah yeah I have
a job yeah
a career job no it's like uh I might
leave at any point moment kind of job
yeah
did you go to college I did yeah and uh
I left because it felt kind of felt like
I was just paying to be miserable so I
was like I'll Just Drive a Zamboni yeah
wait you drive as a Zamboni yeah are you
from Canada no uh we have ice here
dumbass
please don't call people dumbass he was
I mean sorry all right
I didn't Drive a Zamboni that's cool yep
you pick up any chicks doing that uh no
no I mean sometimes like the figure
skaters will look at me like I'm like I
got something but they don't really know
the real me I'm just a loser who can
steer yeah and that's what you tell them
driving to zoombo it's kind of like
driving a tractor on ice
that's pretty cool yeah yep I guess to
how you look at it
Amber what do you do for a living
I was a lab tech for years and now I
work for call center
the call center
so what would happen if you got this 21
year old beautiful man on the phone just
be like hey um I'm just like I'm scared
my tongue and I'm like I'm gonna hurt my
tongue can I get a refund
um we will get back to what we were
talking about and why you were calling
you try to steer back to what you're
talking about yeah
[Laughter]
what kind of products do you uh work
with uh medical instruments metal
instruments medical
instruments wow like uh
gloves
stop naming medical instruments and they
do the testing the machines that they
test your blood on oh okay
do you ever see letter Kenny
I don't know what that is uh they have a
Zamboni driver on there it's really
funny
I don't know yeah wait can I get your
number just in case though
okay Cowboy
over there is Canada this guy is he you
think he likes me oh yeah whatever
well give it up for I can't get your
number all right this guy and Amber it
was nice to meet you thanks thanks for
the opportunity it's got a really small
phone
let's get one more couple up here we got
this sounds like straight male named
Matt B
oh there he comes the muscular man
himself
this sounds like Olive Garden music
this is royalty free we don't have to
pay anyone money for this when you hear
your family Matt B how are you doing
tonight howdy howdy doing good doing
good
so what's the uh key to going on a
successful date
well this will be my first date in like
four years so
wow what happened four years ago I moved
to Japan and I'm not really into that
you're not into Japan the country
I I like girls that know English
wow he wants to communicate he's a
listener I'm all about communication
ladies
what's something you'd like to
communicate to ladies tonight
I don't want to do any speaking I just
want to listen
the perfect man and he's got the ears
for it
[Applause]
could hurt my feelings I hope look at me
you have a dog tag you said you were in
Japan I'm guessing you're in the
military yes I was hell yeah but I guess
the military yeah
we served you guys guess what uh let me
guess you guys are all gonna get shot up
uh Air Force
Navy Army
you got like what two more
yeah [__] hell man star the star one
the the space force yeah that's not
military oh what
doesn't count Marine there you go Ah
hell yeah the ones that are the they
don't even have aggressive and scary
that's cool what did you do in uh
Okinawa or wherever you were
um
it's a weird question a lot a lot what's
really cool that would impress the
ladies what's something cool
is living in in Japan not cool enough
okay let's try
um what did you do there what did I do
there
manage budgets and people like look my
job wasn't exciting guys
he's a smart paper pushers too
he's uh he's good at numbers he can
balance your checkbook
at your own peril
he's a very honest man too he's wearing
dude shoes
dude shoes wow I can read he's a dude
and he's wearing dude shoes he's a very
manly man got a lot of beautiful muscles
at that Amber was talking about Amber
was kind of tantalized by you let's see
what lucky lady gets to take a bite of
this apple
hopefully it's not that one it's Jammy
Reed
much excitement let's go
we got a new uh victim
Jammy with a heart over the eye
she did not sign herself up again this
is a
bunch of rule Breakers over there
signing their friends up
Jamie
does the time start now time's starting
now
okay okay well I know a lot about you
already Okay
um family
yeah
I have a brother I have an older brother
okay yeah he is four years older than me
okay what do you do I work in Tech I'm
actually Anna's manager and Anna was the
one with the Beetlejuice shirt right the
striped shirt that she looked really
great in yeah that was her okay yeah uh
what do you like to do for hobbies
um I like to do all sorts of stuff
um I do I travel a lot I've never been
to Japan though so where's your favorite
place that you've been
um probably Vietnam was great
I just Nicaragua was [__] awesome
um lots of places oh uh favorite sport
um to like this is very important I'm
gonna go with watch
uh Formula One
favorite driver
Danny obviously obviously yeah
I don't watch Formula One okay Daniel
Ricardo oh yeah
you lived in Japan and you don't watch
Formula One I feel like it's big there
I was more of a baseball guy oh okay
yeah they do like American baseball
don't they they love American baseball
that's not like sorry that's something I
think they do right no no for no they
they really do it's awesome I've been to
a Japanese baseball game it's awesome
they have they have girls with kegs on
their backs and they pour it right there
they're called beer girls that's awesome
clever name that's good
that's what I was told it was called
it's possible they were lying to me
sorry I was just gonna ask if he never
spoke to you didn't speak to any
Japanese women when you were over there
I know one phrase in Japanese some of
them are saying
excuse me do you speak English yeah you
lived over there for four years and you
didn't learn any Japanese nope
I worked with Americans and time going
out for American Hero
a guy that speaks English damn it yeah
and Jamie yeah Jamie you were worried
about being racist to Asian people
never mind
so this guy
whoa okay you're an Asian I'm Asian yeah
we're not really offended if you say we
like baseball it's the
it's not the most hurtful thing you can
say to us
I just want to be
respectful
well thank you
of all stereotypes if only met would
show the same amount
for our culture
so did you you know that Japanese women
speak English right like there's some of
them out there have you found any
I wasn't around them a whole lot you
were around a bunch of dudes that's true
big sausage fest to the military is
Ridge is getting excited
I like sausage
you look like it
what you look like you like sausage yeah
okay Colton back up here
so Matt you uh you you asked a bunch of
questions
um you know you didn't know what formula
one was I know what it is I just don't
watch it
you're that's how American you are
true yes that's good and uh Jamie what
did you think about uh his answer
baseball does that make you think he
might be
like traditional
yeah
conservative no I'm just kidding um no I
don't watch baseball either so I don't
really watch many sports at all you
watch F1 though yeah did you go to the
races here uh yeah last year I did yeah
or 2021 yeah it's always crazy it is
crazy did you also go no oh okay
no it's crazy yeah there's just like a
whole bunch of people downtown that's
true there's a lot of people talking in
other languages like this guy says yeah
yes that way you don't like it is
because they're not really hardly any
Americans
there's hardly any Americans that in
Formula One I'm not a big fan of
Motorsports okay I don't know why I'm
I'm more of like a team sport kind of
guy so sure he loves the form of a male
physique
I respect it
I respect that turns to love
yeah sure let's go with that okay uh
Jamie uh you said you are uh managing
Anna how does it feel to know that she
has no idea what her job is honestly I
hardly know what mine is as well it's
fine it's hard to explain what we do
I've noticed that with tech jobs
it's like half made it's actually the
whole thing is made up I would say it's
just well they created my role
[Laughter]
he's not wrong you're not right isn't
that called a Ponzi scheme
no I think Ponzi is the one I don't
punching scheme is where you cheat
the government
you guys work for the government
I did
you did oh yeah Marines apparently does
you currently work for the government uh
technically speaking
for another like two months I'm on
terminal leave I got out this past
Tuesday terminal leave are you trying
I'm getting I'm good you're getting now
I'm just I'm getting out so I'm taking
all the all the PTO that I saved up I'm
taking at the back end to get out early
nice congratulations he's coming out of
the closet
oh wait just the military how long were
you in the military uh five years five
years
cool wow cool
um yeah Jamie what do you uh what do you
think do you think you would ever go to
Japan maybe see the sights yeah yeah to
go to Japan
would you uh learn the language or would
you I'd try to yeah definitely take
advantage of the time there and talk to
people
well you're not doing paperwork like
Matt was there's some pretty serious
paperwork
yeah Matt did you drink the the snake
liquor yes I did that shit's awesome for
those of you who don't know in Okinawa
specifically they have this stuff called
Habu Sake which is a thing of sake that
has the that's been infused with the
Venom of a snake called a Habu which is
one of the most venomous snakes in Japan
um yeah that [__] kicks hard it's
awesome hell yeah I highly recommend the
language highly recommend if you ever go
get get that Habu Sake it's freaking
awesome wow he just did a little
commercial right there
that's cool that you learned that
does that count as a Japanese word
yeah I think it sounds like a motorcycle
I know two phrases
Habu Sake so uh Jamie what's uh what do
you think you think that uh you know you
wanna support the troops or are you
gonna
I typically have a no uniform rule but
um but I got out
so let me do it you're out of excuses
now so any job that has a uniform no
okay
um probably there's like one that like
firefighters okay
but like waiters have to like and like
Air Force is okay too what the [__]
she likes [__]
no manly men like the Marines
we would I gotta ask what does the Air
Force have that I don't
personality
what did you say nothing they're good
with their fingers they're good with
their fingers
um typically you have to be really smart
to get into the Air Force Academy oh she
called you dumb no I'm just saying like
it's it takes a lot up here I think what
it's okay you hate America that's fine I
am not very patriotic you're right oh
okay I didn't want I like America thank
you for your service a little too late
for that I don't know what that was was
that a handshake of support
I like the freedoms I'm sorry she likes
the freedoms that you sacrificed your
hard-earned
paperwork for from some of the people I
also I'm from Colorado so the Air Force
Academy I'm actually like friends with
those slim people that went there so
what about an Air Force firefighter is
that like your ultimate dream
yeah
I fight fires from the air
he's out there it actually it does make
sense that if she's not into uniform and
it makes sense that she's actually into
the air force but
oh well there's really only two branches
of the military which is the Army in the
Navy the Air Force is a corporation and
the Marine Corps is a cult
nice that was some uh you're and you're
a marine yes I am okay did you drink the
Kool-Aid I mean I got out so not very
much of it okay cool do you get like a
pension and stuff though or do you get
to go to college for free I already did
oh nice where did you go University of
Minnesota oh okay
I don't know anything about that so I
can't did you go to the Marines so
that's like Harvard for him
he loves it that's how they joke around
over there
the stereotypes are mostly true
crayons are you can I ask if you were
like conservative are you like
conservative views uh I would say that I
am a leftist which because I found out
if you go far enough left you get your
guns back so like a Libertarian is that
what you were no
libert no libertarianism doesn't work
but no I'm
I'm
like I I'm myself a liberal
who'd you vote I'm kidding
you would get along you both hit America
[Laughter]
I'm just kidding Jamie uh what what's uh
what's your thought process now he's uh
you know he's not one of those Marines
it's more land-based Marine
um
I don't know
I guess I I don't I don't know what
she's at a loss it's awesome she's
yeah she you were ready to listen and
you made her speechless are you guys
both single I am I am yeah is that the
first time that's happened tonight yes
Jovan and Amber you're adorable by the
way so cute yes and happy birthday
ah [__] Jovan I guess
he's a funny guy you were a fun guy the
buffet oh my God
well give it up for uh Matt and Jamie
the last date of the night
thank you so much for coming out
what do you think Rich we saw love
tonight I don't think I'm gonna be any
better dating after this so why not take
him to a buffet take her to a buffet
tell them you're in the Marines let her
order soda
rich is uh online he's a very funny
comedian he's touring all over I go to
Ohio Ohio
obviously an Ohio based cop
he's very funny please check him out
um anything you want to plug no that's
good all right yeah
uh yeah this was fun I enjoyed it well
give it up for Ridge Hershberger thank
you guys so much for coming out good
night
thank you